Die 2. Liga, sie ist spannend wie eigentlich immer. Und wir wollen heute nicht nur auf den Stand in der Liga blicken, sondern nochmal genauer auf den FC St. Pauli, auf Wehen-Wiesbaden und auf den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Und das tun wir mit Moritz Kreilinger, Sonja Riegel und Tim Eckstein jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Ich freu mich! 30 Spieltage sind gespielt. Es wird richtig ernst in der 2. Liga. Es ist wieder einiges passiert. Höchste Zeit für eine neue Ausgabe der Ligatur, zu der ich euch ganz herzlich begrüße, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodom.social und bei Gloosgeil und ich begrüße jetzt bei mir zum einen Moritz Kreilinger. Moritz, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Dann ist Tim Eckstein hier. Hallo Tim.
Moin, danke für die Einladung.
Und mit dem eindeutig besten Hoodie von uns allen, Vieren Sonja Riegel. Hallo, schön, dass du da bist. Ja, stimmt. Als ich es gesagt habe, fies mir dann auch langsam auf. Aber dein ist auch schön. Ja, danke. Gibt es noch in 6XL im Shop für 30% Rabatt. Freund von mir hat sich den sogar gekauft, weil seine Größe schon weg war. Er sieht jetzt lustig aus. Ich grüße dich sehr herzlich. Ja, lass mal auf die Lage in der Liga blicken, Sonne. Du darfst gar mal anfangen. Was war denn so am letzten Spieltag los? Was waren für dich neben Wehen-Wiesbaden natürlich die interessantesten Geschichten?
Ja, da hast du ja die interessanteste Geschichte schon vorweggenommen. Aber ich weiß, da reden wir gleich noch genauer drüber, weil es waren ja auch zwei Vereine, die besprechenswert sind sozusagen. Ja, ansonsten, ich meine, wir können natürlich über oben vor allem reden. Also so Kiel gegen Hamburg war ja so ein Schlüssel-Duell da oben. Und da würde ich sagen, das sieht jetzt extrem gut aus für Kiel. Das ist sehr spannend, die dann in der ersten Liga zu haben. Das war so das, was mir so als Erstes irgendwie ins Auge gefallen ist, neben dem eigenen Spiel, was ich natürlich dann verfolgt habe.
Also es war ein 1 zu 0 beim HSV auswärts. Wenn man davon auswärts sprechen kann, soweit ist es ja nicht. 61 Punkte Kiel, damit Tabellen für… Ich weiß nicht, hat jemand von euch drei in das Spiel gesehen? Ich konnte nur das Ergebnis verfolgen.
Ja, ich habe es gesehen.
Nicht komplett.
Im halben Fieberwahn habe ich es gesehen und auch im halben Fieberwahn habe ich das sehr gern geschaut. Und es ist ja für Kiel super, für St. Pauli ist es auch super, für den HSV ist es auch super, weil die werden dann wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr der Zweitliga-Dino sein. Ja. Wenn es das Zweitliga ist, da freue ich mich drüber für sie.
Das habe ich immer noch nicht so ganz verstanden, weil ich habe neulich eine Aufstellung gesehen, da waren andere Teams viel länger dabei, wie zum Beispiel Nürnberg, aber ist ja egal.
Es geht ja am Stück, es geht ja ununterbrochen. Ununterbrochen sind Kiel und HSV, die sind zeitgleich in die Liga gekommen. Ich muss jetzt überlegen, ob ich Quatsch erzähle, dass Kiel vielleicht ein Jahr früher, St. Pauli auf jeden Fall, seit 13 Jahren in der Liga, seit 2011 sind die wieder drin. Und der HSV dann ab nächster Saison wahrscheinlich dienstältester Zweitligist.
Aber schaffst du es mir, ohne Problemik zu erklären, was da beim HSV los ist?
Ich glaube, es ist ein ganz großer Haufen Verunsicherung. Ich glaube, die letzten Jahre, die spielen da gar nicht so mit rein. Also diese typische, diese Frühjahrsmüdigkeit, die man dem HSV immer vorwirft. Ich glaube, das ist so nicht der Fall. Ich glaube, die Entscheidung an sich, Stefan Baumgart zu holen, ist auch nicht falsch. Ich glaube, der Zeitpunkt ist brutal falsch gewesen. Ich glaube, sie haben auch auf dem Transfermarkt eine falsche Entscheidung getroffen, weil die Innenverteidigung der Weakspot ist, seit Vuskovic gesperrt ist. Und da ist einfach, ja, wurden einfach nicht, hätte man im Winter vielleicht noch nachrüsten sollen. Und es war dann auch immer wieder ein Problem. Als Baumgart dann kam, hat er es geschafft, die Defensive so ein bisschen zu stabilisieren. Aber anscheinend ja, wie man dann auch gesehen hat, auf Kosten der Offensive. Also das, was sozusagen bei Tim Walter immer funktioniert hat, die Offensive, aber die Defensive eben nicht. Das war dann genau andersherum bei Steffen Baumgart, dass das halt ein bisschen besser ausgesehen hat. Defensiv als Offensiv. Auf der anderen Seite muss man auch dazu sagen, der Haas war auch eines der Teams, die am meisten, die ihrem eigenen Expected Goals werden hinterher hinken. Das muss man auch mit dazu sagen. Und das ist auch die letzten Jahre schon so gewesen. Also und irgendwann, wenn das jetzt ins 7. 2. Liga-Jahr geht und das ist auch 7-
6. 2.
Liga-Jahre, dann muss man vielleicht auch sagen, okay, das hat vielleicht dann auch nicht mehr ganz so viel mit Pech zu tun. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ganz schön schwere Zeiten, die hier in Hamburg aufziehen für einige.
6 Punkte Rückstand, jetzt auf Rang 3. Habe ich nicht sogar im Kicker gelesen, Sebastian Kehl wird da jetzt ins Gespräch gebracht, Moritz. Kann das sein?
Ich glaube, der Sebastian Kehl, der muss erstmal noch jetzt mit dem Lars Ricken Gespräche führen. Und dann entscheidet sich, wie es mit ihm weitergeht.
Es geht immer so schnell im Fußballbereich. Aber gut, Rangnick ist ja auch schon Bayern-Trainer, wie wir alle wissen. Moritz, was waren denn für dich so die wichtigen Geschichten des Wochenends?
Ja, ich gucke ja zwangsläufig mehr auf den Tabellenkeller und musste feststellen, dass ja doch einige Vereine ja beschlossen haben, nicht bis zum Ende, um den oder gegen den Abstieg zu spielen, je nachdem, wie wir das sehen. Irgendwie Osnabrück scheint sich wohl doch eher nach unten zu verabschieden. Dafür finde ich bemerkenswert, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt die Vertragsverlängerung mit Uwe Koschin hat bekannt zu geben. Finde ich, es ist ein mutiger, aber auch nachvollziehbarer Schritt, weil ich finde, er hat im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten, die er dort vorgefunden hat, eine gute Arbeit gemacht. Ja, und auf der anderen Seite scheinen auch Magdeburg und vielleicht auch Braunschweig gar nicht bis zum letzten Spieltag zittern zu wollen, sondern das schon vorher klarmachen zu wollen. Was dann vielleicht wiederum dem FCK zugute kommt, weil der muss ja bekannterweise noch gegen beide spielen.
Ich verstehe, wie du denkst. Magdeburg nämlich bei Rostock gewonnen. Das war ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Auswärtssieg. Damit jetzt 36 Punkte. Damit hat man fünf Punkte Vorsprung. Was denkt ihr Sonja Schalke auch bei 36 Punkten? Zwar nur unentschieden bei der SV Elversberg, aber mit fünf Punkten davor sind die jetzt auch durch?
Ja, also natürlich muss man das sagen, was ich glaube, am vergangenen Wochenende jeder in jeder Situation gesagt hat, rechnerisch ist es noch nicht durch. Aber ich würde schon sagen, gerade wenn man sieht, wie sich jetzt einige da unten anstellen, über die wir dann gleich noch reden. Und wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass Osnarder jetzt schon so gut wie weg ist, dann würde ich schalke schon Hoffnung machen, dass sie damit jetzt eigentlich durch sind, dass sie sich irgendwie durchgewurschtelt haben, jetzt auch mit den vielen Unentschieden.
Ja, faszinierend, wie das dann doch sich hinten raus wieder sortiert. Und Braunschweig hat eben in Osnard Brück gewonnen. Über dieses Spiel haben wir sehr lange gesprochen, in der letzten Ligatur. Braunschweig geht es dann drei Punkte vor. Und wie es genau unten ausschaut, würde ich sagen, schauen wir uns dann gleich noch an. Gibt es noch irgendwas Wichtiges, was wir übersehen haben? Tim, ist die Meisterschaft wichtig, die Zweitligameisterschaft, oder geht es nur darum, aufzusteigen? Fünf Punkte Vorsprung sind es aktuell auf Rang 3.
Also mir persönlich ist das total wichtig, weil ich Bock habe, also diese Felge, die man da gewinnt, die hätte ich schon total gerne im Vereinsmuseum stehen. Also mir persönlich ist es sehr wichtig. Natürlich, klar, ich steige auch gerne als zweitplatziertes Team auf mit dem FC St. Pauli. Bevor ich gar nicht aufsteige, dann auf jeden Fall, egal ob erster oder zweiter. Aber wenn ich die Möglichkeit habe, dann will ich das auf jeden Fall. Und ich wäre auch persönlich beleidigt vom Team, wenn die am letzten Spieltag noch die Schale holen könnten und sich aber nicht so reinhängen. Ich meine, das ist ja angesichts des Gegners, ist das vielleicht noch eine andere Thematik, aber auch da wäre es vielleicht nicht ganz fair, wenn man sich dann hängen lassen würde, weil man schon durch ist oder so.
Ich glaube, es sieht schon anders, aber da können wir gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Letzte Geschichte, die man noch ansprechen muss, ist der KSC, die sich so derp einfach in den Hintern beißen werden, dass sie in der Hinrunde nicht so gut performt haben. Hinrunde nur Rang 12, Rückrunde dritter, jetzt auch schon wieder gewonnen im Freundschaftsduell mit Hertha BSC 3 zu 2. Aber das wird nicht reichen. Gibt es denn hier irgendjemanden in der Runde, der glaubt, dass sich im Aufstiegsrennen noch wesentlich was tut? Also wir haben auf 1 Kiel, auf 2 St. Pauli 61 Punkte, 60 Punkte. Dann Düsseldorf mit 55 Punkten und dann den HSV mit 49 Punkten. Boriz, wird das auch so? Also 1 zu 2 kann sich noch drehen, aber sind die ersten drei jetzt fix?
Ich hatte ja insgeheim darauf gehofft, dass Steffen Baumgart die Relegation gegen Köln spielen darf. Aber angesichts des Rückstands glaube ich da nicht mehr dran. Ich glaube, dass die ersten drei tatsächlich in der Reihenfolge auch reinfahren, außer vielleicht Kiel und Pauli noch mal um die Meisterschaft spielen. Aber ich glaube, dass Düsseldorf den Relegationsplatz macht.
Also eigentlich total langweilig da oben, Tim.
Ja, also ich hoffe nicht, dass Timo Schulz die Relegation gegen St. Pauli spielt. So rum ist es dann eher bei mir.
Das vermeidet er eigentlich auch gerade relativ erfolgreich.
Ich glaube, wenn ich mir das Restprogramm jetzt anschaue, dann würde ich sagen, dass das bei Holstein Kiel vielleicht noch ein bisschen kritisch werden könnte, obwohl die eigentlich momentan den stärksten Fußball spielen. Aber jetzt zu Hause, FCK, Moritz wird es überstehen.
Sichere Sache.
Und dann spielen die aber am vorletzten Spieltag empfangen die Fortuna Düsseldorf ja bei sich. Und am letzten Spieltag fahren die nach Hannover. Und Hannover ist tatsächlich das Team, was sich wahrscheinlich mit dem KSC zusammen am meisten ärgern muss, weil die haben so unfassbar viele Unentschieden gespielt. Also die spielen auch echt guten Fußball. St. Pauli war ja da jetzt am Wochenende und das war echt, das ist nicht ohne damit. Marcel Halzenberg, dem merkst du halt an, dass der eigentlich noch Champions League kicken kann und einfach, naja, jetzt 2. Liga spielt und ja, das ist ein bisschen wie Cheaten fast, aber das ist halt brutal für andere Teams. Also es ist wirklich, die sind echt gut und spielen auch echt eine gute Rückrunde und haben aber echt viel zu viele Unentschieden gespielt in der Rückrunde, um da oben noch eingreifen zu können. Und ich hoffe für Stefan Leitl, dass Martin Kindt da die Ruhe behält und das auch so sieht, dass das einfach eine kleine Ergebniskrise oder eine größere Ergebniskrise ist und nicht unbedingt tatsächlich eine Qualitätsfrage ist, weil dann könnte das was, könnte dieser 3-Jahresplan, den Martin Kindt mal ausgerufen hat, dann könnte er nächstes Jahr tatsächlich aufgehen, weil die sind richtig gut in Form.
Und trotzdem aber auch interessant, wie man das dann doch einem Einzelspieler so anmerkt, dass er eigentlich gar nicht in diese Liga gehört.
Ja, es ist Wahnsinn. Also gerade bei Marcel Halzenberg, wenn der dann alleine, also da gab es Situationen jetzt am Wochenende, dann steht er alleine, St. Pauli presst ja gerne hoch, also die pressen zumindest pontiert, pressen die hoch, also im Moment, wenn dann so der das Signal da ist, dann gibt es richtig Alarm und dann sind da vier Leute, die auch echt gute Pressingspieler sind, um den herum und der mit drei Körpertäuschungen hat die alle ins Leere gestickt und schlägt dann einen langen Ball über alle Köpfe hinüber, punktgenau im Lauf von rechts außen. Also es ist wirklich so, dass ich, klar das sind nur so kleine Momente und das ist vielleicht dann auch ein bisschen idealisiert, was ich jetzt mache, aber es ist schon so, dass man wirklich merkt, dieser Spieler ist einfach echt viel besser als das Grundniveau der Liga.
Aber das heißt, da freust du dich dann richtig auf die Erstliga-Saison mit St. Pauli, wenn du das jetzt schon so vor Augen geführt bekommst?
Ja, in gewisser Art und Weise schon. Ja, ich würde tatsächlich gerne sehen, wie Fabian Nürzler Spiele angeht, wo dann die individuelle Qualität nicht pari ist. Also momentan ist ja so, dass St. Pauli auch von der individuellen Qualität zu den Top 5, Top 6 gehört, vielleicht sogar zu den Top 3. Und taktisch auf jeden Fall eins der Teams ist, die am meisten, also das ist ihre größte Waffe auf jeden Fall. Mich würde interessieren, wie das noch funktioniert, wenn das dann von der individuellen Qualität vielleicht nicht mehr ganz für die Top 5, Top 6 der Liga reicht. Ob das dann auch noch so aufgeht. Wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so, aber ob dann, was dann für Veränderungen drin sind und so. Also ich freue mich da riesig darauf, sich da mit den Besten zu messen. Dafür haben wir jetzt als FC St. Pauli auch einfach lang genug in dieser Liga verpackt. Ich muss da mal raus jetzt. Du hast es vorhin gesagt, du magst die 2. Liga auch gerne und da ist immer was los. Und dadurch, dass von oben und unten immer neue Teams dazukommen, ist halt auch viel Fluktuation drin und man erlebt, kriegt viele Geschichten mit. Es ist immer aufregend und irgendwas passiert immer, aber ich bin reif auf jeden Fall. Ich muss da mal raus. Also auch wenn es nur ein Jahr ist, ich muss mal raus da.
Ja und man idealisiert es ja auch so ein bisschen. Es ist natürlich viel los in der Liga, aber als jemand, der sehr viel Erstligafußball sieht und immer nur mal so ein bisschen Zweitligafußball, kann ich auch mit voller Gewissheit sagen, das ist schon ein anderer Fußball. Es ist alles so ein bisschen wie auf 0, 75 Geschwindigkeit Erstligafußball. Also ich gucke manchmal so das Zweitliga-Topspiel, lasse ich, während ich die Statistiken zu irgendwelchen anderen Spielen recherchiere, so nebenherlaufen. Das ist für mich so ein Dauner eigentlich, wie so ein Feierabendbier. Das bringt mich ein bisschen runter. Aber Tim, dann lass doch mal bei St. Pauli bleiben. Zwar immer noch die Fünf-Punkte-Vorsprung auf Fortuna Düsseldorf und das sieht alles ganz wunderbar aus, aber hätte man jetzt nicht in Hannover am Wochenende mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen, würden wir glaube ich in einer ganz anderen Laune hier sprechen. Denn aus den letzten drei Spielen zwei Niederlagen. Das 1 zu 2 beim KSC haben wir auch damals in der Sendung schon kurz besprochen und dann ein völlig weirdes 3 zu 4 zu Hause gegen Elbersberg. Aus neutraler Sicht ganz fantastisch, muss man sagen, auch wie spät die Tore gefallen sind und so weiter und so fort. Aber welche Art von Sand ist denn da auf einmal im Getriebe?
Ich glaube, das wissen auch alle heute noch nicht, was da los war. Ich glaube, da kam es auch so manchmal auf Momente drauf an. St. Pauli war da gegen Elbersberg auch gut im Spiel, lag ja zweimal in Führung sogar und hat das Ding komplett aus der Hand gegeben und wurde da auch – ich glaube, die wurden überfahren. Ich stelle mir das so vor, als wenn man wie so ein Boxer, der irgendwie so einen völligen Überraschungsschlag kassiert und danach einfach nicht mehr wieder richtig in so einen Kampf reinfindet, weil er dann doch schon so ein bisschen angenockt ist. Also irgendwie, da waren in der ersten Halbzeit, in den ersten 20 Minuten waren da zwei Aktionen, wo die einmal komplett überspielt wurden, was man von denen auch gar nicht kennt, dass die sich so recht einfach ausspielen ließen und danach haben die einfach nie so richtig ins Spiel gefunden, aber waren trotzdem ebenbürtig. Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass sie komplett auseinandergespielt wurden von Elbersberg, sondern halt ja doch schon auch viel investiert haben. Aber das hat so niemand kommen sehen, das haben die Spieler auch danach gesagt, dass die das gar nicht richtig einordnen konnten. Die Niederlage vor gegen die KSC war ja eine, wo man dann ja doch auch schon sagen kann, dass das erstens, wie du schon gesagt hast, der KSC auch einfach brutal gut drauf ist momentan. Und das war ja schon so, dass ein, zwei Schiedsrichtereinscheidungen vielleicht nicht ganz so aufgegangen sind, wie man sie sich wünscht in anderen oder wie sie gefällt werden in anderen Situationen. Und St. Pauli da auf jeden Fall auch die Chancen hatte, das Spiel zu gewinnen. Und Elbersberg, das ist so das erste Mal in dieser Saison, dass man das Gefühl hat, die haben richtig den Faden verloren. Also komplett auch die Contenance irgendwie. Also so richtig, dass da auf einmal nichts mehr aufeinander passte, dass die auf einmal in Sachen Rest und Rückverteidigung, dass das auf einmal gar nicht mehr zusammenpasste. Dass die so einfachste Prinzipien, die sie immer haben, dass die Abläufe nicht passten. Und deswegen war gerade dieses Spiel gegen Hannover auch so eins, wo man mit so einer ganz großen Ungewissheit reingegangen ist. Ist das jetzt erlebend? Kommen die jetzt in ein komplettes Loch, ein mentales Loch? Nehmen die jetzt davon was mit, von dem Elbersberg-Spiel? Und gegen Hannover in der ersten Halbzeit haben die auch echt ganz schön viel Schrott gespielt. Also das ging auch echt so weiter. Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Also da haben die auch gegen Elbersberg und Hannover zusammen so viele Torschüsse aufs eigene Tor kassiert wie in den letzten zehn Spielen der Hinrunde insgesamt. Nur in den beiden Spielen. Das ist einfach Wahnsinn gewesen, was da passiert ist. Und die meisten davon gegen Hannover auch in der ersten Halbzeit. Und dann haben die so eine Art Metamorphose durchlaufen im Laufe des Spiels und wurden dann immer stärker. Und am Ende war das wieder der FC St. Pauli, den man kennt, vom Großteil der Saison. Und dieses Spiel hat… Also ich habe echt… Mir ging es nicht gut. Gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Meine Kinder haben einen neuen Vater kennengelernt in diesen 90 Minuten auf jeden Fall. Also nichts, was ich irgendwie gerne vor mir her trage. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass man dieses Spiel unfassbar viel Mut gemacht hat jetzt für den Rest der Saison, für die letzten Spiele. Dass man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, so mit dem… Dieser Sieg in Hannover war etwas, wo man eine große Tür aufgetreten hat und jetzt muss man nur noch durchgehen. So fühlt sich das an.
Und gleichzeitig wäre es aber ja schon wichtig vielleicht auch für die nächste Saison, Schlüsse draus zu ziehen. Mehr als nur, naja, wir haben damit nicht gerechnet, was da jetzt eigentlich gefehlt hat. Denn in der 1. Liga kann man, glaube ich, noch leichter in solche Phasen mal rein stolpern, aus denen es dann schwieriger ist, rauszukommen. Spielt da dann vielleicht eine Verletzung und auch Sperre von Eric Smit eine Rolle? Du hast mir mal, als wir gemeinsam ein Spiel gesehen haben – war das nicht sogar auch gegen Kiel, als ich in Hamburg war? Genau. Da hast du mir ja nochmal seine Rolle auch erklärt, die er hat im Team. Ich habe auch in einem anderen Podcast gehört, dass auch jemand wie Elia Saath, der ja auch sehr wichtig war, so ein bisschen in der Formkrise zu stecken scheint. Also, sind das noch so kleinere Erklärungsansätze?
Genau. Das kam dann halt auch mit dazu. KSC war das schon so ein bisschen. Da gab es so ein kleines Fragezeichen. Elversberg schon ein größeres Fragezeichen. Allerdings jetzt gegen Hannover auch. Also Personalprobleme waren jetzt so das erste Mal so, dass es wirklich größere Probleme gab und Eric Smeed sich so ein bisschen durch die Rückrunde schleppt und er ist einfach ein zentraler Spieler im Aufbau. Ich habe über Marcel Halzenberg gesprochen. Ich würde Eric Smeed da auch mit auf dieses Level heben. Vielleicht nicht ganz, so ein bisschen drunter, aber dahinter kommt halt lange nichts. Das muss man schon sagen, was so Aufbauspieler angeht. Und ja, klar, wenn solche Spieler fehlen, die kannst du nicht so ersetzen. Das fällt dir natürlich dann irgendwann auf die Füße, Elias Saad. Genau, der ist in so einer kleinen Form tiefer. Das hat Fabian Hürzler heute auf der Pressekonferenz. Das hat er auch ganz offen und ehrlich dann angesprochen, als er danach gefragt wurde und hat beschrieben, was da das Problem ist, dass diese Unbekümmertheit fehlt und dass er da sich selber auch rausziehen muss. Dann war Dapo Afoulaian. Der war auch verletzt. Der ist jetzt auch wieder zurückgekommen gegen Hannover. Er hat da auch ein richtig starkes Spiel gemacht. Genau, diese Personalprobleme, die spielen da auch mit rein. Letztendlich ist das so eine Mischung aus vielen Sachen, die da irgendwie mit reinspielen. Vielleicht gab es dann auch die eine oder andere taktische Entscheidung, die nicht ganz so gepasst hat. Vielleicht lässt man natürlich auch ein bisschen nach, wenn man dann auf einmal vor dem KSC-Spiel bis zu 11 Punkte vor dem Relegationsplatz und da rechnest du natürlich schon durch. Und ich muss ehrlich gestehen, ich habe das auch schon gemacht, ich habe auch schon durchgerechnet, nicht mehr ob, sondern wann wir aufsteigen. Und da kann mir natürlich niemand erzählen, dass das im Team nicht auch irgendwas macht, dass man nicht dann irgendwie denkt, ja, okay, das wird schon, der Vorsprung ist so riesig, wir haben das eigentlich, wir sind mit einem Bein, sind wir schon oben. Aber dass das so nicht funktioniert, das hat man dann glaube ich gemerkt. Also diese zwei Niederlagen, die kamen jetzt echt zur rechten Zeit. Wenn man sich das anschaut, was so in den Vorjahren passiert ist, Heidenheim, Darmstadt beim Aufstieg oder auch viele Teams davor, die lange dann auch an der Spitze waren. Diese Dellen gibt es immer und diese Dellen braucht es glaube ich auch, damit man dann auch wirklich da irgendwie durchgeht. Gerade die Teams, die lange oben an der Spitze sind. Ich beende mich an Magdeburg, als die aus der 3. Liga aufgestiegen sind oder Elversberg in der Saison. Die hatten auch zum Saisonende hin, kurz vor Saisonende hatten die so Dellen. Das ist glaube ich ganz normal, dass dann irgendwann diese gewisse Spannung nachlässt, wenn man das Gefühl hat, so jetzt läuft hier was von alleine. Weil verdammt nochmal, wir gewinnen hier alles. Jetzt läuft das von alleine und wenn man da nachlässt, dafür ist die 2. Liga ja bekannt, dass man da eben immer die volle, maximale Intensität auf den Platz bringen muss. Weil sonst ist egal, ob da jetzt Rostock, egal ob da Osnabrück kommt. Ich weiß wovon ich rede, weil St. Pauli hat in Osnabrück genau wegen sowas unentschieden gespielt, weil sie da eben diese Intensität, weil sie da so ein bisschen nachgelassen haben, in Führung gegangen, dann haben sie nachgelassen und das darf dir einfach nicht passieren in der 2. Liga. Und vielleicht spielt dir das damit rein. Genauso wie Verletzungs-Sorgen und und und. Ist mir alles egal jetzt. Wir haben gegen Hannover gewonnen und jetzt spielen wir gegen Hansa und danach gegen HSV und dann ist hoffentlich alles bingo bongo.
Ja, aber gerade weil wir uns hier alle auch so sicher sind, Mensch, da tut sich gar nichts mehr im Aufstiegsrennen und uns ja die Geschichte zeigt, doch es tut sich immer noch was im Aufstiegsrennen.
Deswegen habe ich ja gesagt Kiel.
Also wenn ich mir angucke, Fortuna des Dorf, engster Konkurrent, die spielen jetzt noch gegen Schalke, die sind zwar rechnerisch noch nicht durch, aber so gut wie durch. Die spielen gegen Nürnberg, für Nürnberg geht es schon seit einem 30-jährigen Krieg um nichts mehr. Dann bei Kiel, ok, alles klar, schwieriges Auswärtsspiel. Und dann zuhause gegen Magdeburg, die sich zumindest dem Anschein nach auch gerettet haben, würde ich sagen, sind auf jeden Fall drei von vier machbar. Wenn ich mir über St. Pauli angucke, jetzt zuhause gegen Rostock, mit all dem, was zu allen Rostock-Spielen mit dazu gehört, plus die sind gerade richtig auf Alarm, haben eine total unglückliche oder zumindest schmerzhafte Niederlage, ich weiß nicht, ob sie unglücklich war, das habe ich nicht gesehen, gegen Magdeburg kassiert. Dann beim HSV, der HSV hat nichts mehr zu erreichen, außer euch die Saison zu vermiesen. Und dann Osnabrück hast du schon gesagt. Und dann kommt ja am letzten Spieltag dann Sonjas Wehen-Wiesbaden. Da habt ihr ja schon angekündigt. Da wird sich ja Wiesbaden dann retten. Das ist ja quasi schon gesetzt.
Ja, also meine Rechnung ist ein bisschen anders, weil Düsseldorf spielt ja Samstagabend auf Schalke und Schalke ist in der Rückrunde zu Hause noch ungeschlagen und die robben sich da ja auch so ein bisschen raus. Und durch viele Unentschieden, die dürfen auch von mir aus gerne Unentschieden spielen gegen Fortuna, wir gewinnen zu Hause gegen Hansa und dann kann St. Pauli mit dem Sieg im Volkspark aufsteigen. So ist meine Rechnung.
Okay, ich sehe gerade, Schalke ist ja tatsächlich auswärts 18. Meine Güte, wir hatten das hier schon mal besprochen, aber ich wusste nicht mehr, wie schlimm das ist.
Genau, deswegen, also du sagst es, schweres Auswärtsspiel hat Düsseldorf in Kiel, die haben auch ein schweres Auswärtsspiel auf Schalke auf jeden Fall.
Okay, und ihr steht im Volkspark auf. Na ja, wir werden es sehen, aber wir sehen quasi, du bist optimistisch und du hast ja auch einen Grund dazu, muss man ja sagen. Ich wollte nur einmal kurz darauf hingewiesen haben.
Ich weiß, ich fahre mich hier auch gerne rhetorisch an die Wand, das ist gar kein Thema. Du nimmst das hier, wir nehmen das ja hier auf. Alle wissen, es ist vor dem Hansa-Spiel und ich bin hier voller Euphorie und freue mich einfach auf dieses Spiel. Ich meine, es geht ja einfach gar nicht größer, was momentan ist. Du bist irgendwie als St. Pauli-Fan, du kannst aufsteigen, du spielst zuhause gegen Hansa, das ist ja sowieso von der Brisanz, da ist da ja immer was drin. Dann fährst du in den Volkspark, da hat man schon, als der Spielplan rauskam, hat man schon gesagt, so hö hö hö, und dann im Volkspark aufsteigen und so. Und jetzt bist du irgendwie, hast du das Gefühl, oh Mann, das kann vielleicht tatsächlich passieren. Und du denkst dir, ey, wie irre ist denn das? Allein schon, dass du jetzt am Freitag kannst du gegen Hansa gewinnen und mit dem Sieg steht der FC St. Pauli zum ersten Mal seit 70 Jahren. Also seit 1954 würde er eine Saison vor dem HSV beenden. Ich mein, what a time to be alive als St. Pauli-Fan.
Also wie soll ich diese Euphorie irgendwie bremsen?
Das ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
Noch dazu.
Der Hype-Train.
Du glaubst gar nicht, Tim, wie oft ich an dich gedacht habe in den letzten Tagen, weil es sind ja wirklich nur noch vier, fünf Absagen, bis die beiden wirklich Fabian Hürzeler als Trainer holen werden. Was du ja hier mal im Rasenfunk gesagt hast. Also das ist ja… Aber das ist dann ein anderes Thema, da ruf ich dann nochmal an. Das wird dann besonders. Also ihr habt es alle gehört, wie es jetzt laufen wird, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und wir können es ja halbwegs entspannt sehen. Tim dann vielleicht auch wieder so, dass seine Kinder ihn wiedererkennen. Ich wünsche es dir zumindest sehr. Und das mit der Saison vorm HLV, da hatte ich noch nicht drüber nachgedacht. Das ist natürlich tatsächlich eine Sache. Aber wir wollen ja nicht nur nach oben blicken, sondern wir wollen auch nach unten blicken. Denn da ist es ungemein enger. Also ich habe es schon gesagt. Magdeburg 36 Punkte, Schalke 36 Punkte, Braunschweig 34. Und dann Sonja kommt Wehen-Wiesbaden mit 32 Punkten. Und ich weiß nicht, ob du das gehört hast. Wir haben vor zwei Wochen hier so ein Power-Ranking der Abstiegskandidaten durchgeführt. Und da kam Wehen-Wiesbaden nicht so gut bei weg, auch wegen des Restprogramms. Also man spielt eben noch zu Hause gegen Heustern Kiel, zu Hause gegen St. Pauli. Haben wir ja gerade schon angesprochen. Und dazwischen noch gegen Fürth und in Braunschweig. Braunschweig gerade so ein bisschen so ein Team der Stunde. Wie ist die Lage gerade bei Wehen-Wiesbaden? Hat dieses 1 zu 1 auf dem Betzenberg für dich was verändert? Ganz so euphorisch wie Tim wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht sein nach dem Wochenende.
Wollte ich gerade sagen. Eben hast du dich gefragt, wie kann man diese Euphorie bremsen? Auf jeden Fall, indem man in den Abstiegskampf guckt. Einmal nach Wiesbaden und gleich nach Kaiserslautern. Damit ist die Euphorie dann gebremst. Ich würde schon sagen, dass es ein bisschen was verändert hat. Ich meine, die kamen aus einer Serie mit vier Niederlagen. Wenn du das dann verloren hättest, dann wärst du ja dann endgültig mal unten drin gewesen in den letzten drei. Das ist ja auch, es fühlt sich so schlimm an seit Wochen, aber sie waren ja tatsächlich die ganze Saison über immer über dem Strich. Das hat sich in der Blitz-Tabelle kurz geändert, als Lautern vorne lag und dann haben sie es doch irgendwie wieder eingefangen. Ja, also es ist, glaube ich, so, wie Karzynski gesagt hat, es war einfach wichtig für den Kopf, diesen Ausgleich zu haben. Natürlich dann auch wichtig für die Tabelle, aber vor allem dann mal zurückzukommen, endlich mal wieder was zählbares mitzunehmen, mal wieder einen Punkt irgendwie aufs Konto zu kriegen, dass man nicht ganz so durchrutscht. Natürlich ist man trotzdem ein bisschen gerutscht. Du hast Braunschweig eben erwähnt, die sind ja jetzt dann auch davor. Aber also ich glaube schon, dass es zumindest einen kleinen Push noch mal geben kann. Die müssen ihn natürlich irgendwie auch mitnehmen, aber das war schon ganz gut.
Ja, vor allem ja damit auch den FCK auf Distanz gehalten. Und Distanz ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen großes Wort für Zweipunkt der Abstand. Also es ist eine geringe Distanz, kann es ja auch geben. Ich würde gerne Moritz da mit reinholen, weil auch von dem Spiel konnte ich nur mal so zeitweise nur reingucken. Wie fandest du es denn aus lauterer Perspektive, dieses 1 zu 1?
Ja, eigentlich das typische FCK-Spiel der letzten Wochen. Recht gut angefangen, also für die Verhältnisse in der aktuellen Situation, wo man sagen kann, recht gut. Und wir hatten eigentlich Wehen-Wiesbaden im Griff total in der ersten Halbzeit. Also man kann fast so weit gehen und sagen, Wiesbaden ist in der ersten Halbzeit irgendwie halt so ein bisschen, hat sich verirrt in diesem Stadion und wusste nicht so recht, was sie tun sollen. Und dann, darauf gehen wir ja später noch mal genauer ein, wenn wir beim FCK sind. Aber diese krassen Abstürze in der zweiten Halbzeit, das Spiel war das Paradebeispiel dafür. Also ich kann ganz kurz diese Tabelle einwerfen. Wenn alle Spiele in der zweiten Liga zur Halbzeitpause abgepfiffen würden, dann würde der FCK mit 53 Punkten auf Platz 4 stehen. Dafür war das Spiel halt das Paradebeispiel. In der zweiten Halbzeit lief ja gar nichts. Man hat wirklich gebettelt um dieses Gegentor, schon vor dem 1 zu 1 und auch nach dem 1 zu 1. Also ich finde gerade super auffällig, wie die Sechser-Positionen, Philipp Karlocs hat die gespielt und Tobi Raschel nebenan, bzw. Marlon Ritter in dem Spiel, wie weit die sich dann auch haben zurückfallen lassen. Die haben teilweise auf Höhe der Verteidiger gestanden, haben Wiesbaden kommen lassen und wirklich überhaupt keine Gegenwehr mehr gezeigt. Und so kannst du kein Spiel gewinnen. Und als Kaiserslautern kannst du auch so keine Führung über die Zeit bringen.
Noch dazu, weil ja Sonja – und darüber haben wir ja glaube ich das letzte Mal, als wir hier zusammengesprochen haben, auch schon ein paar Worte verloren – weil ja Wehen-Wiesbaden erstaunlich stabil ist in dieser Saison. Und da gab es natürlich so gewisse Phasen, die haben wir jetzt ja auch damals schon besprochen. Jetzt kam noch eine schlechte mit dazu. Aber vielleicht hat die ja jetzt geendet mit diesem 1 zu 1. Zumindest, du hast es ja beschrieben, welche Situation generell – also jetzt aus den letzten sechs Spielen hat man vier Niederlagen – jetzt eben zwei unentschieden. Und da war eben das gegen den FCK jetzt das letzte. Hat sich da nochmal was verändert bei Wiesbaden, dass man jetzt in diesem Spiel nicht verloren hat und eben zurückkommen könnte? Hatte man Pech in den Spielen davor? Erzähl mir mal so ein bisschen, wie ihr überhaupt in diese Situation reingerutscht seid.
Ja, also würde ich sagen, tatsächlich beides so ein bisschen. Also das mit dem Pech, das würde der Verein dir sofort sagen, ja klar hatten wir Pech, weil da war irgendwie das Tor gegen Osnabrück, was nicht gezählt hat, wo eigentlich überhaupt kein Foul zu sehen war und so. Und die rote Karte gegen Düsseldorf, ob man die geben muss, ist auch wieder eine Frage. Es war also bereits keine klare rote Karte, die Lider bekommen hat. Da spielst du halt lange in Unterzahl und so. Also der Verein würde da auf jeden Fall sagen, ja, da war viel Pech dabei. Aber es hat auch immer so diese Überzeugung gefehlt, fand ich. Also das du sagst, okay, da zählt ein Tor nicht, aber eigentlich musst du gegen Osnabrück, wir haben schon drüber geredet, die sind hier zu gut wie weg, musst du auch genug Chancen haben, um dann Tore zu machen, die auch zählen. Also da war irgendwie nicht diese Überzeugung, dass die Spiele gewinnen können dabei, so für mein Gefühl irgendwie. Und gegen Lautern, das muss man jetzt auch so sagen und Moritz hat es gerade auch schon beschrieben, hattest du aber auch einen Gegner, der relativ dankbar nachgelassen hat. Also es war halt wirklich so, von Wehen wurde er langsam stärker in der zweiten Halbzeit, als sie dann auch am Spiel teilgenommen haben. Und ich scrollte so durch meinen Feed, ich glaube bei Twitter war es oder so, und habe dann schon von ein paar Leuten gelesen, ja typisch, dass der FCK wieder eine Führung verspielt. Und da dachte ich so, Moment, Moment, ist mein Stream irgendwie, hängt der, bin ich nicht live oder so? Weil da haben wirklich schon Leute geschrieben, kein Wunder, dass die die Führung wieder verspielen. Da war der Ausgleich noch lange nicht gefallen. Ja, eben, das irgendwie wusste es schon jeder. Nur so als jemand den SVW verfolgt, dachte man so, hm ja, ob die jetzt wirklich noch einen Ausgleich schießen, mal sehen. Und es war ja dann auch ein wunderschönes Tor, aber du kannst dich ja jetzt auch nicht darauf verlassen, dass da aus über 20 Metern so ein Ding irgendwie reingeht. Am Ende hätten sie es tatsächlich vielleicht auch noch gewinnen können. Es war dann so eine ganz komische Lage, weil man hatte das Gefühl, beide Vereine wollen jetzt irgendwie keinen Fehler machen, aber beide Vereine hätten es drauf, einen Fehler zu machen. Also wenn ihr versteht, was ich meine, es war wirklich so, dass man dachte, mit ein bisschen mehr Überzeugung hätte das auch jeder noch für sich entscheiden können und es wäre ein absoluter Big-Point im Abstiegskampf gewesen. Ich glaube, jeder Verein sagt sich, oh Gott, wir haben gegen die nicht gewonnen, gegen wen wollen wir jetzt eigentlich noch gewinnen? Also so vom Gefühl her, würde ich jetzt sagen. Es ist jetzt kein Zufall, dass der SVW so da unten reingerutscht ist, finde ich. Diese Überzeugung gefiel, dass sie zwar defensiv sind, sie sind mit der Gegentoranzahl immer noch ganz gut dabei, also für Vereine, die da unten stehen auf jeden Fall, aber so nach vorne ist das dann doch schon ziemlich wenig.
Aber was fehlt denn da? Ich meine, wir sind ja – Markus Koczynski war ja auch mal Trainer beim FC St. Pauli – und dieses Defensiv-Kompakt und vorne ist jemand wie Pritain und macht die Dinger fest und dann hat man hoffentlich zwei schnelle Außen, die das regeln. Das kennen wir sehr gut, aber was hat denn da in der Hinrunde funktioniert, was jetzt nicht funktioniert? Ich meine, zwischendurch habt ihr ja irgendwie vier oder fünf Spiele in Folge gewonnen in der Hinrunde. Und liegt das dann an – ich meine, Florian Stritzel ist ja als Torwart, hat er ja unfassbar viel festgehalten in der Hinrunde – ist das vielleicht so eine individuelle Qualitätsfrage, dass der nachgelassen hat?
Nein, das würde ich nicht sagen. Er ist schon immer noch so mit einem Garant. Also, eigentlich können sie sich bei ihm bedanken, dass sie so gut dastehen. Gerade auch, wie du sagst, in der Hinrunde hat er super viel rausgefischt, das ist aber jetzt nicht so, dass er auf einmal nichts mehr hält. Also, es ist wirklich eine gute Frage, warum da nach vorne weniger geht. Es ist so, es fehlt so eine Art von Überzeugung, die davor da war. Und ich kann dir nicht sagen, wo sie hingegangen ist. Und weil du diese Serie aus der Hinrunde jetzt angesprochen hast, das waren ja jetzt genau diese Spiele, die sie jetzt eigentlich bis auf Lautern verloren haben, dann alle. Also, das war diese Serie und das waren zwölf Punkte, von denen haben sie auch immer noch brutal gezehrt, also eigentlich die ganze Zeit, so bis jetzt. Ja, das war so ein Zwischenspurt, der ihnen richtig gut geholfen hat und der ihnen jetzt aber so langsam nichts mehr hilft.
Und was hat Markus Skorczynski versucht zu verändern? Wenn ich mir jetzt nur hier die Statistiken angucke, dann sehe ich eine Umstellung von Dreierkette auf Viererkette zum Düsseldorf-Spiel hin und da hast du ja schon gesagt, da hatte man auch viel Pech und wir haben auch zum Beispiel im Forum hatten Düsseldorf-Fan geschrieben, Mensch, Wehen-Wiesbaden hat echt einen gepflegten Ball gegen uns gespielt, da sind wir ganz gut davongekommen mit dem 2 zu 0. Ist das quasi Mittel der Wahl gewesen oder hat da eine Verletzung mit reingespielt? Warum hat Kowalczynski das verändert?
Einmal kurz, Max, Fortuna Düsseldorf kommt überall gut weg. Tatsächlich. Die haben echt, also es muss man auch mal sagen, Siegesserie hin oder her, aber ich habe den Eindruck, Fortuna Düsseldorf kommt immer gut weg.
Jetzt gönn halt mal irgendeinem Verein irgendwas, wenn nicht sein VW.
Wehen-Wiesbaden würde ich jetzt gönnen. Ich finde, ich finde nämlich auch, die spielen einen echt gepflegten Ball.
Ja, und die können nämlich nicht aufsteigen aktuell. Okay, gut, aber ich nehme es zur Kenntnis. Feedback bitte an Tim direkt. Also Sonja, Umstellung auf Viererkette. Warum?
Ja, das musst du ihn dann fragen. Also er macht eigentlich gar nicht so viel am System dann immer mal. Also hinten so mal drei, einmal Vierer und so. Das ist ja eigentlich heutzutage normal, dass man da nicht fest genagelt ist auf ein System. Also, dass der SVW fest genagelt war. Auf Viererkette war das am Anfang nach dem letzten zweitlicher Aufstieg. Und da haben sie viel zu spät gemerkt, vielleicht müsste man ein bisschen flexibler sein. Deswegen ist das dann einfach so diese Umstellung auf Gegner. Manchmal ist das auch vorne. Manchmal sind es zwei Stürmer und manchmal sind es dann irgendwie doch nur zwei Offensive mit einem Stürmer. Das ist so, das würde ich jetzt gar nicht so groß hängen. Ich würde es eher, wenn man es so ein bisschen größer nimmt. Wir haben ja in der Hinrunde auch schon mal gesprochen, hast du ja gesagt. Und da waren es wenig Tore. Da wurde immer wieder gesagt, so ja, woran hakt es denn in der Offensive? Und dann haben sie versucht, das so ein bisschen umzustellen, dass sie ein bisschen spielerisch besser werden. Und das hat noch nicht so 100 pro gefruchtet. Das fruchtet dann vielleicht, dass irgendwer sagt, auch eigentlich haben die ganz gut Ball gespielt, aber sie müssen es ja auch irgendwie in Tore kriegen. Und das sehe ich noch nicht so richtig.
Gut, jetzt sind es ja auch nur noch vier Spiele. Die Gegner haben wir ja schon besprochen. Jetzt kommt aber in die ganze Situation noch mit rein, dass man den Sportdirektor verloren hat an Darmstadt 98, bei denen sich ja auch Moritz ganz gut auskennt. Das ist wirklich eine sehr praktisch zusammengestellte Runde. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ihr alle drei in dieser Konstellation Zeit hattet. Da hatte ich großes Glück. Wie groß und wichtig ist dieses Thema? Ist es vielleicht auch ungünstig, dass das jetzt passiert in so einer entscheidenden Saisonphase?
Ja, natürlich. Also, ich glaube, das ist damit schnell beantworten. Natürlich ist es super beschissen. Also, ich weiß nicht. Natürlich hast du auch, wenn du einen Sportdirektor in der Phase bist, auch derjenige, der vielleicht überlegen würde, ja, wirft man nochmal einen Trainer raus, wechselt man da nochmal was oder so. Dafür ist so eine Position dann auch entscheidend. Da ist jetzt ein totales Vakuum da. Ich glaube jetzt auch nicht, dass sie irgendwie Kocilzki noch rauswerfen, gerade nach diesem Punkt Lautern. Das ist ja, denkt man jetzt erstmal, okay, ist jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen die Kurve gekriegt.
Aber wäre das vorher eine Möglichkeit gewesen, das entlassen wird?
Das weiß ich tatsächlich nicht, weil ich habe bei SVWW das Gefühl für Trainerentlassungen verloren. Beim letzten Mal, das kann ich dir sagen. Die sind ja tatsächlich beim letzten Mal mit dem Trainer in die 3. Liga gegangen, beim Abstieg mit Rüdiger Rehm damals. Und das war ja, da hat man ja auch überlegt, macht man dann irgendwie einen Neuanfang und sagt man nimmt einen neuen Trainer ein. Sie haben gesagt, wir machen mit ihm weiter. Und dann haben sie ihn aber in der 3. Liga zu einem Zeitpunkt entlassen, der ganz komisch war, der bis heute nicht erklärbar ist. Und man fragt bei allen Seiten irgendwie nach und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwas intern passiert ist, weil das war so der erste Impuls, den man damals hatte, vielleicht auch als Außenstehende, weil mich haben so viele Leute angefragt, was ist denn da passiert? Warum entlassen sie denn an dieser Stelle jetzt den Trainer? Das war ja in der Hinrunde. Man stand jetzt nicht so geil da in Sachen Aufstieg, aber man stand jetzt auch nicht unten drin oder so. Also das war so, dass ich auch wirklich bis heute denke, dass das war ein komischer Zeitpunkt. Jetzt nicht, dass die Verpflichtung von Kauzinski danach irgendwie schlecht gewesen wäre. Sieht man ja, das ist ja jetzt auch schon ein Verhältnis, was sehr lange hält. Aber an der Stelle habe ich so ein bisschen mein Gefühl dafür verloren. Weil früher war der SVW der ganz normale Club, fängt mit irgendweren die Saison an und dann läuft es nicht und dann fliegt er irgendwann raus. Und dann kommt der nächste und dann hält man vielleicht irgendwie die Klasse und dann läuft es aber wieder nicht und dann fliegt er raus. Es gab mal eine Zeit, da war das quasi im Jahresrhythmus. Davon sind sie ja schon lange weg. Das Einzige, was mir dazu noch eingefallen ist, ist, dass Kauzinski diese Situation ja irgendwie in Dresden schon mal hatte. Dass er kurz vorm Aufstieg entlassen wurde, als der Aufstieg noch mal so in Gefahr geraten ist für Dresden damals, als er dann als vermeintlicher Aufstiegstrainer noch mal kurz vor Knappe irgendwie den Posten räumen musste. Ich sehe diese Gefahr jetzt irgendwie nicht, aber ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, wer sich da gerade groß die Gedanken drum machen kann im Verein.
Ich wollte sagen, Trainerwechsel zu komischen Zeitpunkten, nicht verständlichen Zeitpunkten, das sind vielleicht Spezialitäten von Südwestdeutschland, Kaiserslautern, Resklüssen.
Vielleicht einfach mal so ein Trainertausch.
Ja, darf ich eine Sache zu Fernie sagen? Was mir gefallen hat, war zumindest die Reaktion, die aus Wiesbaden kam, gerade Nico Schäfer, der das auch öffentlich und sehr deutlich diesen Zeitpunkt kritisiert hat. Weil im Endeffekt ging es ja in Darmstadt recht ähnlich mit Carsten Wählmann im Winter. Mit dem Unterschied, er hat jetzt keine Ausdrucksklausel gezogen, sondern er hat seinen Vertrag gekündigt, weil er war einfach unbefristet. Und in Darmstadt haben sie sich damals öffentlich eigentlich nur wohlwollend dazu geäußert, haben aber hinter verschlossener Tür wirklich gejammert und sich beschwert. Und jetzt, wo der Abstieg ja quasi durch war, haben sie das Thema, hat Thorsten Lieberknecht das Thema ja auf der Pressekonferenz noch mal rausgekramt und quasi so im Nachhinein noch mal hinterher geschossen. So ja, auch Wehmann ist schuld, so unser Kader, etc. pippe.
Aber warte mal kurz, hatte Wehmann nicht damals zum März gekündigt und dann hat Darmstadt gesagt, nee, dann die Wintertransferperiode sollst du dann auch nicht mal machen, geh bitte früher. Also hat er nicht eigentlich alles so gemacht, wie man es machen sollte?
Sie werfen ihm ja in Darmstadt immer noch vor oder sagen sie auch so, das hat Rüdiger Fritsch auch gesagt, er wäre ja dann nicht mehr mit vollem Herzblut dabei gewesen. Aber was mir halt einfach gefallen hat, war die Reaktion in Wiesbaden, klipp und klar gleich zu sagen, hey, das ist eigentlich scheiße und in Darmstadt so ein halbes Jahr lang irgendwie nichts zu sagen und ganz ehrlich, wer im Glass House sitzt, weil Darmstadt profitiert ja jetzt genau von der Situation, die auch Kirsten Willmann ausgenutzt hat. Also das fand ich so in dem Verhältnis der beiden Vereine irgendwie nicht so ganz sauber.
Ja, und es war dann auch lustig vom Zeitpunkt her, weil das sich lieber Knecht auf dieser PK beschwert hat. Das war ja ein paar Tage, bevor dann diese Ferni-Sache ins Rollen kam. Also da hat man sich dann schon gedacht, okay, ihr hört ja euch irgendwie selber zu. Also ich meine, in beiden – du hast es eben auch beschrieben – was ist so mit den Vertragsverhältnissen, okay, kannst du machen, ist halt dann für deinen Verein beschissen. Also da war jetzt kein Fehlverhalten im vertraglichen Sinne, aber da steht natürlich jeweils ein Verein da und guckt doof, ne?
Und das hat in einer ganz wichtigen Phase und hat natürlich noch die kleine Pointe, dass Wilmann jetzt zu einem Erstligisten wechselt, zu Heustern Kiel und dann wieder ein Erstligakader zusammenstellen darf. Da haben sich dann eventuell mit Wehen-Wiesbaden gemeinsam in der zweiten Liga trifft, das muss man noch sehen. Aber die ganze Planung, die man jetzt machen muss, man muss ja sowieso schon zweigleisig planen, aber das ist schon ein sehr schwieriger Zeitpunkt, wobei es wahrscheinlich den guten Zeitpunkt – ja, vielleicht am ersten Tag nach der Transferperiode – das ist wahrscheinlich der beste, nach Ende der Transferperiode natürlich, das ist wahrscheinlich der beste Zeitpunkt, noch irgendwie so eine sportliche Führungsfigur zu verlieren. Aber angenehm ist es nie. Wie blickst du denn jetzt auf die verbliebenen vier Spiele, Sonja?
Ja, eigentlich eher so ein bisschen zittrig, würde ich sagen. Also ich sehe jetzt noch nicht so den kompletten Push, dass es wirklich dann klappt. Hofft man natürlich drauf, aber vielleicht haben sie Glück und es ist jetzt gut, dass das erste Spiel gegen Führt ist, weil das sind ja wirklich die, für die es jetzt um nichts mehr geht. Danach, wir haben es jetzt auch schon an anderen Stellen anklingen lassen, kommen ja so Knackerspiele gegen oben und unten. Aber mit Führt hast du jetzt wirklich, für die geht es, glaube ich, auch rechnerisch um nichts mehr. Also da ist wirklich alles irgendwie durch. Und wenn du die jetzt zu Hause hast und du hast generell drei Heimspiele, ein Außerspiel noch, vielleicht hilft dir das auch ein bisschen, weil, glaubt zwar in Wiesbaden immer keiner, aber eigentlich haben sie ja inzwischen für die eigenen Verhältnisse eine ganz gute Zuschauerzahl und so. Deswegen, aber ich meine, was hier dann am Ende da blöden kann, ich meine, du spielst in Braunschweig, die sich vielleicht dann mit einem Sieg irgendwie retten können. Kiel kann vielleicht rechnerisch aufsteigen in Wiesbaden. Also das gerade auch dadurch, dass es ein Sonntagsspiel ist, kann sich das so ein bisschen verschieben dann schon. Also natürlich, theoretisch können sie dann, glaube ich, auch schon aufgestiegen sein, dadurch, dass es ein Sonntagsspiel ist. Da muss aber wirklich dann alles passen. Und ja, das ist dann halt so Wundertüte. Weißt du nicht, was dich erwartet. St. Pauli, hoffen wir jetzt mal alle, dass sie durch sind am letzten Spieltag und, weiß nicht, in Badelatschen spielen. Aber ja, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen, hat man ja von der letzten Saison noch das Gefühl, was bringt dir so ein letzter Spieltag? Weil man kann jetzt gar nicht sagen, so ja, das sind Experten vom letzten Spieltag, weil der letzte Spieltag der letzten Saison ist immer noch so ein bisschen ambivalent. Weil du hast ein Spiel gewonnen, was du gewinnen musstest, dann hast du gefeiert, dann hast du auf einmal gemerkt, es reicht aber nicht. Also war das jetzt ein guter letzter Spieltag oder nicht? Also es ist natürlich, wenn sie sich drehen und sagen, klar hat am Ende alles geklappt, aber ja, ich bin da echt noch ein bisschen wackelig. Also es ist so, gerade wenn man so die Tendenz ansieht, wie es immer weniger wurde, der Vorsprung nach unten. Ja, das wird noch knackig jetzt.
Und bei welchem Verein hast du am meisten Angst, dass er Wehen-Wiesbaden noch überholt? Rostock oder Lautern? Aus einer Brücke nehme ich jetzt raus.
Gute Frage. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich der größte Vorteil, dass da jetzt niemand mehr drunter steht, der auch gerade einen Megalauf hat. Also dass da alle gerade ihre Derben-Probleme haben. Ich glaube, das ist der größte Vorteil, den SVPW gerade hat, wenn es überhaupt noch irgendwie einen gibt. Lautern, das schien mir schon ziemlich kaputt. Wir reden gleich auch darüber, was da zwischen Trainer und Sportdirektor, die da ganz verschiedene Auffassungen haben, von schaffen wir es überhaupt noch, ist der Renegationsplatz jetzt unser Ziel oder wie auch immer und so. Die Frage ist ja, wie viele Punkte reichen dann? Wenn ihr so ein Spiel gewinnt, ein Spiel unentschieden, dann reicht es schon, weil der SVPW auch nichts mehr reißt. Kann die halt immer trotzdem noch passieren. Was wir vielleicht auch erwähnen müssen, was jetzt noch nicht so angeklungen ist, ist halt auch super knackig von den Punkten her. Gerade im Vergleich zur 1. Liga. Es war vor ein paar Wochen noch drastischer. Jetzt hat sich ja Mainz da oben und da rausgespielt. Aber wenn du es so verglichen hast, wie viele Punkte sind die Abstiegsplätze da und wie viele sind sie da, dann hast du in der 2. Liga halt auch echt Pech die Saison, dass da viele mit einer ganz okayen Punktzahl gerade unterwegs sind.
Das ist allerdings wahr. Also 30 Lautern, 31 Rostock, 32 Wiesbaden, 34 Braunschweig und dann kommen die 36er-Klubs, die ich vorhin schon raus geredet habe. Aber das ist jetzt der perfekte Zeitpunkt, um Moritz hier nochmal intensiver ins Verhör zu nehmen. Ja, Moritz, was ist denn los zwischen Trainer und Sportdirektor und überhaupt auf dem Betzenberg?
Ja, ich bin vorbereitet. Ich werfe euch erstmal noch zwei Zahlen in die Runde. Ich habe ja schon diese 53 Punkte zur Halbzeitpause angesprochen, die ja eigentlich zeigen, dass der FCK prinzipiell nicht unbedingt ein Abstiegskandidat sein muss. Wenn wir uns den X-Goals-Wert anschauen, dann ist der FCK fünfter. Wenn wir uns den X-Gegentor-Wert anschauen, dann hat der FCK auch den sechstbesten Wert. Und das passt natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr zusammen, weil der FCK hat mit 59 Gegentoren die zweitschlechteste Abwehr der Liga. Es ist ja so eine totale Ambivalenz in dieser Saison, was Kaiserslautern angeht. Du bist irgendwie das erste Saisontrittel, bist du irgendwie auf Aufstiegskurs, dann der totale Einbruch. Und es ist super schwierig, das alles zu erklären. Und die Gründe für diesen Einbruch, die sind so vielfältig, die liegen in den Trainerwechseln, die liegen in der Wintertransferperiode. Das haben wir auch alles in der letzten Ligatur intensiver besprochen, auch rund um die Personen Enes Hayri und Thomas Hengen. Da will ich jetzt heute gar nicht mehr groß drauf eingehen. Dieses Spiel Wiesbaden, um das nochmal ganz kurz aufzugreifen, das war jetzt die 11. 1-0-Führung, die du verspielt hast, und es war die 4. 1-0-Führung in den vergangenen fünf Spielen, die du verloren hast. Und das fällt jetzt gerade unter Friedhelm Funkel so extrem auf. Es ist halt, wenn du Friedhelm Funkel holst, dann weißt du eigentlich, was du bekommst. Du wirst jetzt hier keinen Offensivfeuerwerk abfeuern, sondern Funkel ist dann erst mal solide, defensive, soll stehen. Und er übertreibt es aber halt, weil die Mannschaft schießt ja das Tor, und die Mannschaft kann Tore schießen. Sie hat ja im Vergleich zur Konkurrenz da unten die klar beste Offensive. 46 Tore sind es, glaube ich, oder? Hast du Tabelle vor Ort? Und danach verlässt er sich oder verlässt sich die ganze Mannschaft halt total auf diesen Vorsprung. Und die Mannschaft kann einfach keine Ergebnisverwaltung betreiben. Das hat sie jetzt mehrfach bewiesen. Wenn diese Mannschaft in so eine Passivität abrutscht, dann geht es einfach nicht lange gut. Und dieser Kader ist ja für, ich sage mal, für Dirk Schuster Fußball eigentlich ausgerichtet gewesen in der vergangenen Sommer-Transferperiode. Und dieser Dirk Schuster Fußball, der besteht ja auch zum Teil aus hinten so ein bisschen passiv stehen, aber dann halt aus total schnellem Umschaltspiel, sofort nach vorne, Konterfußball. Und das ist eigentlich das, was diese Mannschaft kann. Und darauf ist die auch ausgelegt. Du hast viele schnelle Spieler. Du hast so mit Marlon Ritter so einen für die 2. Liga, finde ich, zuweilen echt genialen Mann in der Zentrale, der Ideen hat. Und ich habe so das Gefühl, diese Mannschaft steckt gerade in so einem Korsett. In diesem Korsett, sie darf nicht so richtig. Und so beraubst du sie irgendwie ihrer Stärke. Und so ist die irgendwie nur noch ein Schatten von dem, was sie eigentlich sein kann.
Ja, also du hast es ja angesprochen mit der Offensive, dass die so stark ist. Hast du das Gefühl, dass das, also mein Eindruck von Kaiserslautern ist, dass das total unausgeglichener Kader ist? Nämlich genau das, dass du mit Ragnar Ache so einen völligen Überspieler hast da und aber allgemein die Offensive echt individuell so stark besetzt und die Defensive da nicht so richtig mithalten kann und dann kannst du auch nicht, wenn du so ein starkes Gefälle in der Mannschaft hast, dann kannst du da eigentlich auch keine Lösung für finden, dass das einigermaßen ausgeglichen auf dem Platz aussieht. Schätzt du den Kader auch so ein oder habe ich nur das Gefühl, dass die Defensive von Kaiserslautern einfach nicht Schritt halten kann mit der eigenen Offensive?
Da gehe ich ganz mit dir und das ist ja auch wieder miteinander verknüpft, dass du zum Beispiel einen Timo-Théos Puchas als Linksverteidiger spielen lässt. Der ist ja eigentlich, wenn er ein Linksverteidiger ist, ein Linksverteidiger als Schiedensspieler am Rande einer Fünferkette. Weil er halt wirklich offensiv stark ohne Ende es flanken schlagen kann. Aber das ist kein Linksverteidiger für eine Viererkette. Und das ist auch Friedhelm Funkel. Friedhelm Funkel spielt halt gerne Viererkette. Und deswegen drückt er dieser Mannschaft sein System auf. Und das ist jetzt halt die Viererkette. Auch auf der rechten Seite ist Jean Zimmer, der ja auch in Düsseldorf und wo er schon war, auch häufiger eher Schiedensspieler oder sogar rechtes Mittelfeld gespielt hat, ist jetzt auch nicht der klassische defensiv starke Rechtsverteidiger. Und dann hast du im Grunde noch zwei Innenverteidiger, die jetzt Boris Tomiak und Jan Elvedi, die jetzt vom Namen her jetzt nicht super schlecht sind. Die können schon zweite Liga spielen. Aber es passt halt einfach im Gesamtkonzept dieser Mannschaft nicht. Das ist eigentlich keine klassische Holding-Six. Die wollten eigentlich alle Trainer haben und keiner hat sie bekommen. Deswegen hast du das Recht, Tim.
Und trotzdem war doch, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, wir haben ja noch aus alten Tribüngesprächzeiten einen lauten Chat, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, Boris. Und also ich will es jetzt nicht raussuchen, aber gab es nicht damals Euphorie deinerseits und von Sebastian Zobel? Also fast Euphorie ist ein bisschen viel, aber schon sehr positives Wohlwollen für diese Entscheidung Friedhelm Funkel zu holen?
Ja, die begründete ja aber auch in erster Linie darauf, dass er auf Dimitrios Kramotsis gefolgt ist und damit habe ich alles gesagt. Also Kramotsis war wirklich, man muss es so klar sagen, die größte Fehlentscheidung auf der Trainerposition dieser Verein in den letzten zehn, fünfzehn Jahren. Es hat vom ersten Tag an nicht gepasst, es hat in der Art und Weise der Kommunikation nicht gepasst. Tim, du hast es auf St. Pauli erlebt, wo er sich das Eigentor geschossen hat, wo er nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, er wollte hier Ergebnisverwaltung betreiben, im Endeffekt den Rückstand halten. Er hatte bei den Fans von der ersten Sekunde an kein Standing und er hat es natürlich auch in der Hinsicht schwer gehabt, dass er auf Dirk Schuster gefolgt ist, der wirklich der beliebte Weingasse ist, Lautern und für dessen Entlassung es jetzt heinsportlich gesehen eigentlich überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit gegeben hat. Aber ja, um zurück auf Funkel zu kommen, Max, ich habe Funkel zu diesem Zeitpunkt für den absolut richtigen Mann gehalten und glaube auch immer noch, dass es deutlich besser ist, mit Funkel die Saison zu Ende zu spielen, als jetzt meinen vierten Trainer da ins Rennen zu schicken, weil diese Mannschaft ja auch total verunsichert ist. Und da ist ja eigentlich die Art und Weise, wie Funkel an so eine Mannschaft rangeht, schon die richtige. Er hat ein Draht zu Spielern, er weiß, wie er die packen kann, wie er die packen muss. Das ist alles gut. Aber ich glaube, er muss jetzt erkennen, dass das, was er bisher spielerisch vorhatte, einfach nicht funktioniert. Und da kommen wir jetzt auf die angesprochene Beziehung. Geschäftsführer Thomas Hengen, Trainer Friedrich Funkel, die wir ja auch freundschaftlich schonmal angerissen hatten. Das Zitat Thomas Hengen, wir dürfen hier keinen Hosenscheiß auf Fußball spielen, ist ja, glaube ich, durch die Gazetten und alle Medien gegangen am Wochenende. Und manche interpretieren da auch schon einen kleinen Riss zwischen Trainer und Geschäftsführer rein. Das glaube ich gar nicht. Thomas Hengen ist jemand, der zwar emotional sein kann, der sich aber der Wirkung seiner Worte immer bewusst ist. Und der wollte einfach ein Zeichen setzen an diesen Tag. Und das sehe ich jetzt auch als völlig legitim an in diesem Moment. Und das ist dann auch mal nicht mit dem Trainer abgesprochen. Ich bin gespannt, was das für Friedhelm Funkel hat direkt im Anschluss an das Wiesbadenspiel Konsequenzen angekündigt. Konsequenzen, die man auch in dieser Woche im Training sehen soll. Ich kann nur so viel sagen, am Dienstag im Training hat man nichts davon gesehen. Aber das war auch die einzige öffentliche Trainingseinheit in dieser Woche. Also es kann auch noch viel passieren bis zum Spiel am Wochenende. Aber klar ist einfach so, wie in den letzten Wochen geht es nicht weiter.
Ja, aber es geht natürlich auch anspruchsvoll weiter. Also jetzt dann in Kiel als nächstes Spiel, dann zu Hause gegen Magdeburg. Magdeburg könnte da den Klassenerhalt sicher machen. Gut ist jetzt ein bisschen konjunktiv, weil wir nicht wissen, wie der nächste Spieltag verläuft. Dann bei Harter BSC, da war doch auch was. Gab es da noch eine öffnende Rechnung aus dem DFB-Pokal? Ja, die gibt es. Keine Ahnung, ob das eine Rolle spielt. So wie ich Fußballspieler kenne, ja, spielt eine Rolle. Und dann zu Hause gegen Braunschweig, bei denen wir aktuell noch nicht sagen können, in welcher Situation die dann sein werden. Für Lautern wäre es ja fast schon gut, wenn die durch wären zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Also ich nehme jetzt quasi aus deinen Worten mit, so wie es jetzt gerade läuft, kann es nicht weitergehen. Es muss sich quasi auch vom ganzen Ansatz etwas verändern. Friedhelm Funkl muss vielleicht erkennen, dass er nicht mit dem spielen kann, was ihm nahe liegt, sondern was vielleicht auch den Spielern eher näher läge. Und das muss jetzt aber halt auch passieren gegen den aktuellen Tabellenführer.
Ja, das ist das eine und es kommt noch was anderes Grundlegendes hinzu, das spielt da natürlich mit rein und das eine führt dann zum anderen. Aber ich zitiere mal kurz aus dem Kicker, der morgen erscheint, da ist die Überschrift im FCK-Artikel Kollektive Lethargie, weil man hat das Gefühl, dass der FCK, dass diese Mannschaft so ihr Schicksal teilweise einfach über sich ergehen lässt in diesen zweiten Halbzeiten und dass diese Art von diesem zurückhaltenden Fußball auch bei den Zuschauern einschläfernd wirkt. Und dieser Mythos Betzenberg lebt aktuell nur in der Geschichte. Also der Betzenberg, das wisst ihr alle, der kann Spiele mitentscheiden, wenn das Publikum mitgeht. Und das ist einfach gerade nicht der Fall. Und Lethargie deswegen, weil es auch nicht ins Gegenteil umschlägt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr vielleicht du magst, 2008 Milan Zizic, damals der FCK vor dem Absturz in die dritte Liga, wo er die Mannschaft hat auspfeifen lassen vor der Kurve. Aber auch dieser, ich nenne es jetzt mal dieser emotionale Hass, auch der ist nicht vorhanden. Der Einzug ins DFB-Pokalfinale verfälscht natürlich auch so ein bisschen den Blick und auch dieser gute Saisonstart. Es ist ja irgendwie gar nicht alles richtig schlecht und so. Trotzdem stehst du jetzt mit einem Fuß in der dritten Liga. Aber das eine führt zum anderen, meine ich, deswegen, wenn du wieder hier mitreißenderen Fußball spielen würdest, der der Mannschaft liegt, dann geht ja auch das Publikum viel mehr mit, gerade in Kaiserslautern. Und dann kann dieses Spiel – ich rechne mir, also ich rechne für Kaiserslautern in Kiel nichts aus. Kiel 6 Spiele in Folge zu Null gewonnen. Also ich sehe nicht, wie. Ich sehe tatsächlich dieses Spiel in Kiel als ein Testlauf für den FCK. Du kannst jetzt natürlich nicht dieses Spiel her schenken, aber du kannst es einfach probieren. Du musst versuchen, mitzuspielen, auch wenn es am Ende schiefgeht. Und dann die Woche drauf ist halt Magdeburg für den FCK ein total unangenehmer Gegner. Da haben sie sich in den letzten Jahren immer super schwergetan. Dieser Fußball, den Christian Titz spielen lässt, auch mit dieser Schnelligkeit vorne und Spielfreude, Baris Atik und Co. Das liegt dem FCK überhaupt nicht. Im Worst Case gehst du tatsächlich noch mal mit Null Punkten aus den nächsten zwei Wochen raus und irgendwie dann drauf zu hoffen, dass Hertha schon durch ist, dass Braunschweig schon durch ist und es nicht mal so ganz ernst nimmt. Das ist halt auch eine sehr gewagte Rechnung. Das heißt, wenn ich die Chancen irgendwie beziffern würde, 50-50, ob Relegation oder keine Relegation. Aber ich glaube, direkt der Klassenerhalt halte ich für relativ ausgeschlossen.
Also erstmal muss ich irgendwie gerade an diesen alten Doppel-Sechs-Gag denken. Ich weiß nicht, ob den noch jemand kennt mit diesem, nenn irgendeinen Namen aus dem Fußball-Business. Und es ist unmöglich, dass derjenige noch nie Lauter-Trainer war. Das ist mir gerade so gekommen, als ihr da diese Reise gerade gemacht habt. Ansonsten würde ich nur noch fragen wollen, Moritz, wie du Funkel wahrgenommen hast in der Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel. Weil es war ja, er hat in seinem Fazit, hatte man so den Eindruck, er fängt an, über das Spiel zu reden und dann redet er sich selber irgendwie so ein bisschen Mut zu und fängt dann irgendwie an mit, schaffen wir noch und überhaupt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob er das selber hat kommen sehen, als er angefangen hat zu reden. Das war auch so ein bisschen, mich hat es nicht ganz überzeugt, ich will immer fragen, ob es dich überzeugt hat, wobei die Antwort hast du schon halb gegeben, aber ich wusste nicht, wo das herkommt und ob er das vielleicht an die Spieler so nicht weitergibt, keine Ahnung. Und dann hat er aber auch wiederum im anderen ARD-Interview gesagt, ja, ich bin übrigens Relegationsexperte. Also da hat er irgendwie auch schon so vorgebaut, oder habe ich meistens gewonnen. Ich finde ihn da nicht so ganz überzeugend, auch wenn er doch irgendwie probiert, so einen Zuversicht auszustrahlen, ohne dass er Zuversicht ausstrahlt. Ist das auch so dein Einbruch?
Teile ich absolut. Ich muss sagen, wenn ich mich jetzt in seine Person hinein versetze, ist es natürlich schwer, nach den Leistungen der letzten Wochen und schon wieder in der verschwielten Führung irgendwie begründeten Optimismus auszustrahlen. Finde ich tatsächlich schwer. Aber du hast eben was ganz Gutes angesprochen. Wenn du Friedhelm Funkel fragst, warum schafft der FCK das, ist so mehr oder weniger die Antwort, ja in Köln war es damals noch aussichtslos, wir haben es auch geschafft. Der Funkel FCK oder Friedhelm Funkel beim FCK lebt gerade sehr von Erfahrungen aus seiner Vergangenheit und wie wir alle wissen, zählen die jetzt halt nicht. Also es ist schön, dass es damals in Köln auch geklappt hat, aber die Situation ist eine andere und ja, ich bin da auch skeptisch.
Tim?
Ja, aber gerade wenn du, ich meine, du hast es jetzt gerade gesagt, du bist da skeptisch und du hast auch ja doch relativ klar jetzt auch angezählt, dass er einfach ein falsches System, vielleicht nicht an die Spieler, an den Kader angepasstes System da durchdrücken wollte jetzt und das einfach ganz klar nicht funktioniert hat. Ich meine, also ja klar, das ist schon der dritte Trainer, aber jetzt mal würdest du sagen, da könnte man auch nochmal jemand anders holen für die letzten Spiele? Wird das überhaupt noch was ändern?
Naja, rein rational betrachtet hast du völlig recht und rein rational betrachtet hat Thomas Hengen schon zu zwei Zeitpunkten einen Trainer gewechselt, wo die Situation nicht so festgefahren war. Das war damals, als Dirk Schuster vor der Relegation Marco und Werben ersetzt hat. Damals hat es geklappt und es war dann bei der Freistellung von Dirk Schuster und da hat es halt überhaupt nicht geklappt und auch so nach allen Hintergründen, die ich kenne, muss man die Trainerfindung oder die jüngsten Trainerfindungen in Kaiserslautern als recht uninspiriert und ideenlos bewerten.
Also sprich da ist jemand sein Telefonbuch einfach nur durchgegangen.
Ja, beziehungsweise Friedhelm Funkel war dann vielleicht auch die naheliegendste, prominenteste Lösung, aber auch hier sehen wir jetzt wieder, es ist nicht unbedingt das, was zur Mannschaft passt. Es war halt irgendwie vom Namen her und der FCK-Historie naheliegend und in der Hinsicht passt das auch alles. Und deswegen, Tim, stelle ich mir wirklich die Frage, wenn du Friedhelm Funkel entlassen solltest, wird es danach besser? Also es ist nach Schuster deutlich schlechter geworden und es ist nach Kramozis nicht bedeutend besser geworden.
Das ist die Frage.
Etwas sarkastisch könnten wir jetzt sagen, so den Trainer, den der FCK jetzt bräuchte, der steht eh noch auf der Gehaltsliste. Das wäre vielleicht so ein Dirk Schuster.
Ja, ich meine, also ich finde es halt interessant, es gibt ja bei Teams auch immer, wenn ich das so mitbekomme, gibt es halt diese Überlegung, auch diese Rechnung, macht man das jetzt? Oder überlegt man, ob man es in die Relegation schafft und macht man das dann vor der Relegation, um neue Impulse zu setzen? Oder, oder, oder? Und ich finde das halt spannend, weil für mich, so wie du das beschreibst, liegen halt alle – alles spricht gegen Funkel eigentlich gerade. Also es ist wirklich so, dass ich, also so wie du das beschreibst, es ist, sehe ich nichts, was jetzt dafür sprechen sollte. Man muss an diesen Trainer festhalten, außer er ist schon der dritte Trainer in der Saison. Aber das ist ja eigentlich kein Argument.
Es spricht aber ehrlich gesagt auch alles gegen Thomas Hengen. Also auf der einen Seite hast du die Trainerentscheidung, auf der anderen Seite gucken wir uns den Kader an und sagen, wir sind schief.
Dazu kommt aber jetzt halt so ein bisschen der Background in Kaiserslautern. Die regionale Investorengruppe, die diesen Verein ja durch jährliche Millionenschübe am Leben erhält, die hat ja doch mehr zu sagen, als ihr vielleicht rein Statuten auf dem Papier an Stimmen zustehen.
So was gibt es im deutschen Fußball? Ich dachte, die äußern ihre Meinung immer nur zu 49 Prozent.
Ja, und da wird dann auch ein gehöriges Wort mitgesprochen. Und ich sag mal so, das Ganze soll jetzt nicht despektierlich klingen, aber für Leute, die da nicht unbedingt die Fußballaffinsten oder zumindest Insider der Branche sind, für die ist dann Friedhelm Funkel in so einer Situation auch ein toller Name. Also das zieht dann mehr als jetzt – ich will jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber ihr wisst genau so, der klassische Zweiliegerfeuer wäre man jetzt noch mal so.
Ich meine, Friedhelm Funkel hat auf jeden Fall Geschichten, die er erzählen kann, aus seiner Zeit bei Köln und so weiter und so fort und in vielen, vielen Jahrzehnten vorher eigentlich. Und gleichzeitig hat man ja diese absurde Situation, dass man im DFB-Pokalfinale steht und ich schon von prominenten FCK-Fans wie Thomas Schmidt bis hin zu weniger prominenten sieht man alle nur in der Warteschlange hängen für Final-Tickets. Und das wird ja auch das Highlight dieser Saison sein und könnte aber gleichzeitig halt rund um eine Relegation gestrickt sein. Und das wäre ja schon eines der Positiv-Szenarien, dass man es immerhin in die Relegation geschafft hat. Wie blickst du denn darauf? Ehrlicherweise wäre es ja nach allem, was ich vom FCK gelernt habe in den Jahren, in denen ich Fußball-Fan bin, seit Anfang der 90er bis jetzt, würde das ja total gut zum FCK passen, dass man einerseits da wahrscheinlich dann sogar ein ganz gutes Finale spielt, von Gewinnen will ich jetzt nicht reden, ehrlicherweise, und gleichzeitig aber in der Relegation runtergeht.
Ja, ich glaube tatsächlich die Außenseiterrolle. Und Kaiserslautern hat häufig in Außenseiterrollenspiele gewonnen, aber ich glaube so aufsichtslos wie dieses Mal war die Ausgangslage nie. Und genau darin sehe ich so ein bisschen die Gefahr, dass diese Mannschaft, die ist ja auch mental oder im Kopf so. Jan Elwedi hat in der Winterpause – kurzer Blick zurück – einmal gesagt, wir sind ja eigentlich viel besser, als wie wir in der Tabelle da stehen. Und damals war der FCK, ich glaube, 13. 14. also was bei weitem nicht so brenzlig wie jetzt. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem mit dieser Denkweise. Diese Mannschaft denkt, sie ist viel besser und sie zeigt es auch immer mal wieder. Hat es ja in dieser ganzen DFB-Pokalreise gezeigt. Ich nehme jetzt mal das Halbfinale gegen Saarbrücken raus, das war wirklich unterirdisch. Aber ich glaube, dass einfach der Fokus von vielen dann auf dem DFB-Pokalfinale liegt und nicht auf einer möglichen Relegation. Auch weil viele einfach in dieser Mannschaft drin sind, die doch nicht so lange da sind, die jetzt nicht die totale Identifikation mit dem FCK haben, wie jetzt zum Beispiel ein George Zimmer oder auch wie ein Marlon Ritter inzwischen, die dieses FCK-Gen leben und die wissen, was es bedeutet, wenn der FCK absteigt in die 3. Liga, weil die haben beide schon mit dem FCK 3. Liga gespielt. Und für andere ist vielleicht aber dieses DFB-Pokalspiel so das absolute Highlight. Hey, du hast 90 Minuten und kannst DFB-Pokalsieger werden. Das ist für die meisten oder vielleicht für alle in dieser Mannschaft eine einmalige Chance. Und wir wissen ja, wie das ist, wenn im Kopf nur 5% fehlen irgendwie und irgendwie das Relegationsspiel wäre ja dann Mittwochs das erste. Und wenn nur 5% der Gedanken schon auf den Samstagabend in Berlin schauen, dann könnte es ein sehr teures Pokalfinale werden, in diesem Sinne. Oder wie schaut ihr denn von außen da drauf? Wird mich jetzt auch mal interessieren.
Sonja, du wolltest ja eh was ergänzen.
Ich wollte ja eh was ergänzen und zwar nicht auf dieses Jahr, sondern ich würde sehr weit zurückgehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Max sich als Bayern-Fan vielleicht noch daran erinnert. 2006 das Pokalfinale, weil jetzt erzähle ich nämlich damit Funkel nicht immer selber von früher erzählen muss, erzähle ich jetzt von Friedhelm Funkel von früher, als er mit der Eintracht ja auch im Abstiegskampf war und auch ins Pokalfinale gekommen ist und das quasi vorab schon abgeschenkt hat, also zumindest verbal. Also immer ja ja, Abstiegskampf ist wichtiger und so. Das hatte aber damals diese dumme Besonderheit, dass das vor Saisonende gespielt wurde wegen WM und so. Und dann war das so ein paar Wochen vor Saisonende und dann war das einfach so dahergeschenkt. Weil also Liga ist wichtiger, Liga ist wichtiger und ich fand das auch ein bisschen doof. Ich dachte also der Titel ist wichtiger. Hallo, steigst ab, steigst wieder auf. So ungefähr. Natürlich so einfach ist es nicht, aber das ist das, was du so als Anhängersicht dann ja doch irgendwie drin hast. Und deswegen kann ich das schon verstehen, weil als Spielersicht wahrscheinlich auch. Ich mein, im Zweifel wechselst du in einen Verein und spielst weiter, zweite Liga oder wie auch immer und hast aber dann da stehen, du bist Pokalsieger. Deswegen kann ich das aus Spielersicht verstehen. Ich kann es irgendwie auch aus Fansicht verstehen, dass man sagt, boah, Titel wäre schon geil. Und abgestiegen sind wir jetzt so oft, dann sind wir auch wieder aufgestiegen. Aber klar, für einen Verein an sich, irgendwie als Entscheidungsträger im Verein darf man das nicht so sehen. Da würde ich auch nicht wollen, dass das so jemand dann so sieht. Aber jetzt ist die Konstellation ja ein bisschen anders, erst nach der Saison.
Ja, aber zwar ja zwischen den Relegationsspielen, also im Grunde doch mitten der Saison, also falls sie Relegation spielen.
Wird es tatsächlich nicht verschoben?
Also die Relegation wird verschoben, aber Relegation wird dann Mittwoch-Mittwoch gespielt. Also Mittwoch-Gemmelspiel, Samstag-Pokalfinale, Mittwoch-Rückspiel.
Na dann passt meine Funkeltheorie. Dann macht er das wie damals, das passt schon.
Damals feife es an der Hand von Oli Kahn. Das war sie noch. 87. Minute Schuss von einem Frankfurter. Das wäre es 2-2, glaube ich, gewesen.
Das 1-1. Und dann hat er den ganzen Block beleidigt. Da hat er sich umgedreht und alle beleidigt.
Ja, Oli Kahn. Und wer hätte damals gedacht, dass er der vernünftigere von den beiden zur WM 2006 mitfahrenend Torhüter tritt.
Das führt jetzt zu weit.
Das führt wirklich zu weit. Aber wäre das nicht eigentlich auch ein Anlass, Moritz, für die Fans, den Spielern, bei denen das ja nachvollziehbarer Weise wirklich so sein könnte, dass man auf dieses Highlight-DFB-Pokal ein bisschen zu sehr jetzt schon blickt, denen eben das zu vermitteln, was das bedeutet, für den FCK zu spielen und jetzt auch in Heimspielen zu spielen. Und ich meine das jetzt nicht in bedrohender Art und Weise. Das finde ich immer sehr schwierig. Ich kann mich auch erinnern an das Auspfeifen lassen des Teams von Milan Džaržić. Allerdings haben mir bisher Spieler immer gesagt, das bringt einem ehrlich gesagt gar nichts, wenn einen 50.000 Leute beschimpfen. Weil man weiß schon selber vorher, dass man schlecht gespielt hat. Aber im Positiven wäre es ja möglich. Und das haben wir doch auch schon häufig genug erlebt, dass dann eben 8.000 Fans zum Training kommen und noch mal einstimmen. Jetzt auf das Spiel in Kiel, dann auf das Heimspiel gegen Magdeburg. Müsste sich nicht vielleicht das Umfeld selber aus der Letter G rausziehen können?
Ja, die Kraft sollte das, also die Kraft rein mengenmäßig, sollte das Umfeld ja auf jeden Fall haben. Aber auch in der Fangemeinde sehe ich sehr gespaltene Meinungen über dieses Thema. Weil halt viele, die vielleicht das große Ganze, auch das ganze Wirtschaftliche und alle Folgen jetzt nicht überblicken, auch denken, ja klar, lass uns DFB-Pokal-Sieger werden, steigen wir halt ab, steigen wir halt wieder auf. Aber jeder, der sich intensiver mit diesem Verein beschäftigt, weiß einfach, wie dramatisch es wäre, wenn die noch mal runtergehen. Weil der FCK hat erst letzte Woche auf LinkedIn einen Beitrag darüber gepostet, wie der EV wieder personell aufgestellt ist. Die sind irgendwie statt einem Festangestellten sind es jetzt wieder sechs oder sieben. Und was hätte denn einen Abstieg zur Folge? Im Endeffekt, dass du wieder sechs Leute im EV rausschmeißen musst. Und jetzt in der KGAA gar nicht erst angefangen. Da müsstest du auch wieder diverse Stellen streichen. Und selbst wenn wir jetzt sagen, dieser irre Fall, die gewinnen den Pokal, dann hast du halt irgendwie für ein Jahr Europapokal einen an. Gut, dann kannst du das ein Jahr, kannst du das wieder auffedern. Aber wie schwer tun sich Absteiger in der dritten Liga? Wie schwer tun die sich? Und wenn du dann nicht direkt im ersten Jahr wieder hochgehst, dann kommt die Entlassungswelle halt im zweiten Jahr. Und der FCK war bei seinem letzten Drittliga-Aufenthalt mit einem Bein in der Regionalliga. Und wer weiß, ob es nicht nächstes Jahr, also wenn es passiert, nicht dann diesen Schritt geht und dann irgendwie irgendwie ein 1860 wird und ewig da unten bleibt oder ein MSV Duisburg wird, der ja jetzt leider sich auch aus dieser Liga nach unten verabschiedet hat. Es kann für diesen Verein in erster Linie nur um den Klassenerhalt gehen. Aber klar, was machst du? Du kannst ja auch nicht vorher ein Pokalfinale abschenken. Du kannst ja nicht ein Pokalfinale mit einer B-Mannschaft auflaufen lassen. Es ist eine super schwierige Gemengelage und ich will da auch nicht in der Haut der Verantwortlichen stecken, wenn es dann tatsächlich zu dieser wirklich undankbaren Konstellation kommt.
Ja, aber andererseits ist es doch eigentlich einfach. Fünf Spiele, eventuell sieben Spiele Vollgas geben. Und das muss von jedem Spieler verlangbar sein. Und wer es nicht leisten kann, der spielt da nicht. Das muss vom Trainer. Kann man das verlangen, dass er es auch schafft, das zu transportieren, das Umfeld anzuzünden. Und von den Fans kann man es auch erwarten, dass die jetzt alles dafür tun. Meine Güte, das ist ja – also man ist ein Punkt zum Relegationsplatz, zwei zum Nicht-Abstiegsplatz. Ich meine, wir reden hier fast schon in so einem Graveston über Lautern. Aber ey, ist doch noch alles drin. Das muss doch möglich sein. Und da darf man doch auch nicht – also das DFB-Pokalfinale darf da doch auch keinerlei Entschuldigung sein. Seid froh, dass ihr irgendwie da hingekommen seid gegen Saarbrücken. Gut, Klammer drum ist, egal, wie man ins Pokalfinale kommt, ist ja auch eine super Geschichte und ist ja sogar mal ein Zeitpunkt, an dem wirklich große Teile Deutschlands sicherlich dem Außenseiter die Daumen drücken werden. Aber jetzt erst mal vier Spiele und vielleicht halt sechs Spiele Vollgas.
Was noch dazu kommt zu dieser dann ja extremen oder vermehrten Belastung jetzt noch mit sieben Spielen mit englischen Wochen? Ragnar Ache hat anfangs dieser Woche wieder nicht trainiert. Ich meine, es waren jetzt achile Szenenbeschwerden. Und jeder weiß, ich hatte es in seiner letzten Verletzungsperiode ausgerechnet. Ich habe die Zahlen nicht mal im Kopf. Aber irgendwie der Punkteschnitt, wenn Ragnar Ache nicht gespielt hat, war bei 0, 1, 0, 2 irgendwas. Und der Punkteschnitt, wenn Ragnar Ache getroffen hat, war irgendwo bei 1, 6, 1, 7. Nagelt mich nicht fest so irgendwie in dem Dreh. Wenn der dieser Mannschaft im Saisonfinale in einer Relegation, wo auch immer, fehlen sollte, dann hilft nur noch beten.
Es war so klar nach der letzten Saison, die immer so halbwegs ereignislos war, zumindest in lauterer Maßstämme, war so klar, dass wieder so eine ganz normale jetzt kommen würde.
Aber ich meine, diese Delle, die hat man ja letzte Rückrunde schon gesehen. Und ich verstehe immer nicht, wie, also ich meine, da ging es ja damals auch um Demut und zu erkennen, okay, das war jetzt, wir haben die Welle, die Aufstiegswelle sozusagen gut abgeritten, vielleicht ein bisschen besser als der Kader vielleicht auch ist und sind dann ein bisschen abgeschmiert in der Rückrunde. Aber wir können haben irgendwie die Chance, uns zu etablieren in der 2. Liga. Und ich meine, diese Negativspirale, die ist ja einfach über den Sommer weitergegangen gefühlt. Und da hat sich ja nicht viel dran geändert dann. Aber es kommt ja immer wieder auf diesen Punkt dieser Schuster-Entlassung drauf eigentlich. Also weil das ja für so eine Art Ideenlosigkeit widerspiegelt oder anzeigt dann, wenn man das Gefühl hat, okay, wir wollen hier was bewegen, dann kannst du eigentlich nach der Rückrunde der letzten Saison musst du sagen, ja okay, wir wollen was bewegen. Dann kommst du aber mit Schuster auch vielleicht gar nicht weiter, sondern dann musst du vielleicht einen ganz größeren Umbruch denken. Dann gehst du in die Saison mit Schuster. Es läuft genauso wie dann in der Vor-Saison in der Rückrunde. Ich meine, was hast du auch erwartet, wenn du da so weitermachst? Und dann schmeißt du den raus. Die Verwunderung darüber, dass Kaiserslautern so abschmiert, die teile ich nicht so. Auch wenn ich natürlich gesehen habe, dass das mit Gramozis natürlich echt gar nicht zusammengelaufen ist, dass das super krass gewesen ist. Aber diese Negativspirale, die läuft halt schon seit 16 Monaten oder so.
Du hast halt – ich will die Zeit hier, wir sind ja eh schon drüber, gar nicht unendlich sprengen.
Aber es ist so spannend, der Wiedergang von Kaiserslautern. Also ich label da nicht dran, sondern es ist einfach spannend zu sehen, wie so ein Club, bei dem eigentlich so vieles vorhanden ist, um sich wirklich ja doch irgendwie eher in eine andere Richtung zu bewegen, wie das so weggeworfen werden kann, so gefühlt.
Du hast halt nach dem Aufstieg eine Verkettung von Fehlentscheidungen getroffen. Es lief nach dem Aufstieg sportlich wieder gut zunächst, aber der ganze Verein hat sich nicht wieder an die 2. Liga angepasst. Dass du weiterhin mit Thomas Hengen nur einen einzigen Geschäftsführer hast, das ist einfach zu wenig. Im Grunde, wenn du den entlässt, stehst du wieder völlig führungslos da. Es ist eigentlich der Plan schon länger, auch aus diversen Gremien wird es gefordert, dass du dich breiter aufstellst, dass du einen Geschäftsführungsposten auch auf der kaufmännischen Ebene wieder einführst. Das ist so viel, was im Hintergrund einfach nicht läuft. Dann diese – ich muss das wirklich als ominöse Einstellung von Enes Hayri als technischem Direktor bezeichnen, der ja im Grunde die Transfergeschäfte inzwischen erledigt und wirklich auch mit Dirk Schuster konnte er nicht, mit großen Teilen der Mannschaft konnte er nicht, es sind zahlreiche fragwürdige Transfers. Es ist irgendwie, Thomas Hengen hatte in seinen ersten zwei Jahren in Kaiserslautern wirklich ein sehr gutes Händchen, was Spieler angeht, was Trainer anging und dieses Händchen hat er seit dem Aufstieg bzw. dann seit der Rückrunde nach dem Aufstieg einfach völlig verloren und der FCK fällt irgendwie wieder in dieses Muster zurück, das ihn in den letzten zehn Jahren diesen sportlichen Niedergang gekostet hat.
Ich glaube, dieses letzte Segment, das kann man all denjenigen vorspielen, die vielleicht auch aus guten Gründen darüber weinen, dass sich jetzt mit Köln wieder wahrscheinlich ein Traditionsverein aus der ersten Liga verabschiedet und dann vielleicht mit Heustern Kiel nicht die Tradition per se hochkommt. Ich finde, es gibt valide Argumente, sich darüber zu ärgern. Aber wenn man sich die Frage stellt, warum schaffen es denn Traditionsvereine öfter nicht, schaut euch an, was der 1. Läufte Köln diese Saison gemacht hat und in der Transferperiode, in denen sie noch was machen durften, hört euch an, was wir gerade über Lautern gesprochen haben. Und ich weiß, dass Moritz, Hayri, alleine dazu könntest du jetzt noch eine Stunde was erzählen. Du hast es ja schon mal hier angedeutet und so weiter und so fort. Ich werde den letzten Schwerpunkt auch nochmal verlinken.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, damals habe ich doch eine halbe Stunde über ihn gesprochen.
Genau. Und es war genauso unterhaltsam. Ich meine, immerhin, das ist immer da. Der 1. Läufte Köln ist quasi das Popcorn-Emoji als Verein. Es ist immer was los. Und wie es ausgeht, sehen wir dann. Ich bin ultra – ich bin jetzt richtig hyped wieder auf den nächsten Spieltag, muss ich sagen. Ich bin so gespannt, wie das alles ausgeht, wie sich Wehen-Wiesbaden schlägt, was jetzt Rostock macht, ob Kaiserslautern uns nicht vielleicht doch auch positiv überrascht, ob es noch irgendjemanden da unten reinzieht, der jetzt glaubt, er ist schon weg. Der Theorie nach schon auch noch möglich. Ich bin gespannt. Ich weiß, dass ihr drei es auch seid. Aber ich bin erstmal sehr froh, dass ich euch drei hier hatte. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker. Danke dir, Moritz.
Ja, danke für die Einladung. War wie immer schön bei euch.
Aber wirklich, obwohl wir über den FTK sprechen mussten. Danke an Tim Exdin vom Millenton, den ihr natürlich auch alle abonniert und hört als Podcast und als Blog und so weiter und so fort. Danke dir, lieber Tim.
Ja, danke. Es tut mir leid. Ich hab das am Anfang in meiner Euphorie auch gar nicht so so kommen sehen, dass wir uns danach noch eine 50 Minuten über Abstiegs-Sorgen unterhalten. Und ich vielleicht mit meiner guten Laune hier vielleicht eher so ein bisschen, ein bisschen viel am Platz bin vielleicht.
Das war schon so gewollt, dass wir hier quasi Aufstieg und möglicherweise Abstieg rein machen. Und ich sehe ja, dass die anderen ja auch gute Laune haben. Die können ja nichts für die Vereine über diese berichten. So ja auch Sonja Riege, bei der ich mich besonders bedanke, Sonja, dass du dir so kurz vor dem ESC noch Zeit genommen hast. Alle, die uns bei YouTube sehen, die sehen schon, dass du schon voll drauf eingestellt bist. Bei BleistiftRocker.de schreibst du ja auch immer wieder oder führst interessante Interviews. Also danke dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, hier für den Rasenfunk.
Wollte ich mir doch nicht entgehen lassen, hier nochmal schnell über den SVWW sprechen zu können.
Ja, ja, ja, jetzt mal abwarten, jetzt mal abwarten. Wir werden das alles in Ruhe sehen und können ja dann auch bewerten, wie es für die Vereine ausgegangen ist. Und euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich natürlich für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für euren Support, denn der Rasenfunk, er ist und bleibt werbefrei. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Stefan, bei Telehammer, bei Sintram, bei Christoph M bei Philipp und bei ColdSievers. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sie haben sich auch registriert als supporter in den Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Kreditkarte, Paypal, Banküberweisung, alles ist möglich und davon zahlen wir alles, was hier im Rasenfunk stattfindet, inklusive ein kleines Honorar an all unsere Gäste. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung, bleibt gesund, bleibt im Rasenfunk gewogen, empfiehlt uns weiter und bis bald.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt, herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.